welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and quantumania will open Marvel
Phase 5 with Kang the Conqueror as the
vast Cult of Warring Champions that the
Avengers have to face but given Ken's
champ status does it logically follow
that he must have killed Thanos at some
point or at many points the cast and
crew are now specifically pitting Thanos
vs gang and when you go back to re-watch
Loki and Multiverse of Madness Infinity
war end game you can actually pinpoint
these specific Nexus moment when Kang
would have targeted the Mad Titan and
I'm gonna break down what that likely
assassination tells us about the
surprising status of the 616 universe as
we know it in an interview at Brazilian
Comic-Con earlier this month guanamania
director Peyton Reed unprovoked compared
to hang the Thanos we're uh encountering
an antagonist who's unlike anything
they've ever experienced and that
includes Thanos and notice right at the
end of that line Peyton Reed fist bumps
Kang actor Jonathan Majors now Majors
was otherwise tight-lipped in this
interview but was later asked about his
workout regimen and how physical he
would be getting as Kang and we want to
know if you're going to use any of these
workouts you had to do with your Buy on
this next movie all of it all of it all
of it like Hulk no I'm kidding it's
funny because if you read Dynasty Kank
he doesn't fight it's not like a brawl
guy yeah is that going to happen here
you're going to get all of it
I don't know maybe Majors just had
trouble hearing the interviewers it was
really loud in that room but he is
indicating here and has discussed in
other interviews the wide range of
characterizations he would get to create
as Kang as the primary thing that Drew
him to this role and while Peyton Reed
has described this Quantum media king as
a variant who conserves of energy with
major saying all of it and his fist bump
with the director that mentioned him
being more fearsome than Thanos I think
Majors is gonna play at least one king
who makes Thanos say just that for a
drop of blood oh [ __ ] remember in the
quantumania trailer footage that we've
seen so far Kang has implied he has
killed countless Avengers in the past
and we know for sure that Kang is
certainly aware of Thanos Kang variant
he who remains scripted the sacred
timeline in which Thanos was a major
antagonist and Thanos showed up in Loki
episode 2 in the multiple choice
question on Miss minutes training module
Thanos has two apples he eats both the
realized C wants more he goes back in
time 20 minutes and eats the apples
again does this mean the apples will not
have existed in the timeline he left hey
no because time is constantly happening
be the question doesn't matter because
Branch cannot change another time Branch
or say Thanos would have been hungry
prior because the grandfather Paradox
already accounted for the change of
matter before its move when we look back
at this the TVA Rank and finals seem to
suggest B was the correct answer but I
don't know by the Loki season one finale
the true answer seems actually to be all
of the above look whatever your thoughts
on this anyone who thinks that they
firmly understand 100 the logic of Loki
season one and what exactly happened in
that finale is fooling themselves which
is why I am actually revisiting it
currently for a major project that I am
working on announcement coming early
next week but one thing we do know for
sure about this Kang period he remains
is that he made an exception for The
Avengers to use time travel he remains
wanted the 616 Avengers to defeat Thanos
using the Time Heist when Slayer
confirmed this to Loki in episode one
we're not here to talk about the
Avengers oh no no what they did was
supposed to happen you escaping was not
now I have theorized before that he
remains made that exception so that Tony
Stark would later unlock Quantum time
travel with that inverted Mobius strip
in his basement this being the discovery
that Nathan Richards would later build
on and master a thousand years later and
that he who remained scripted this out
so that Stark would die shortly after so
that he would have no time to dismantle
that technology or you know bird in the
ocean like he likes to do with this deck
in fact the more we learn about the 616
MCU the more it starts to seem like it's
less of a sacred timeline but really an
exception to the multiversal norm 6.6 is
like a rogue timeline it's a variant
branch that went unprooned the normal
Marvel universe is probably supposed to
have mutants alongside Avengers right
but he who remains in his campaign to
prune all other Kang Rivals during that
multiversal war that he talked about in
the finale he left one 616 timeline
untouched so that it would keep his own
origin intact basically a massive Kang
tree he remains clipped all other
branches so other carrying apples fell
down to the ground then only one branch
remaining that left the he remains
[ __ ] too high enough off the ground
so hungry country Thanos could need that
Apple that kind of makes metaphors there
but I hope it made sense now I'm on
camera a lot so I have to see my face a
lot so you think I would have to put a
lot of effort in my skincare routine but
you know what I really don't because I
use geology geology is a 15 time
award-winning personalized skincare
company recognized in hype piece burning
Men's Health and Esquire and Aspen
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews and they've recently expanded to
offer products for pretty much whatever
you need all you got to do is take this
30 second diagnostic quiz and geology is
going to figure out your routine for you
like if you need some hair care well use
geology's co-wash it's a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses the hair without
the big lather the harsh ingredients of
typical shampoo and for the rest of your
shower routine you can use their body
washes they're free of harsh ingredients
they smell great and are refillable and
for after the shower protect your skin
from environmental stressors with
vitamin C plus e for Relic serum to keep
your skin looking young and healthy and
then a bit of dermatologist tested
aluminum free deodorant that really
smells great right now for a limited
time geologists is hooking our audience
up with an absolutely crazy offer use
the code new rockstars they will give
you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skincare trial set that
discount applies whether you're stocking
up for yourself or stuffing someone
else's stocking instead either way
geology has you covered check out their
awesome gift sets featuring all of your
favorite geology products to get started
just click the link in the description
take a 30 second diagnostic quiz and
their team of dermatologists will design
a personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door but as a
better example perhaps let's look at
Universe 838 for Multiverse of Madness
this universe had no Tony Stark present
currently but it was still a universe
where he once existed based on those
Ultron sentries walking around there's
also a universe with an Illuminati
formed by Stephen Strange who have led
them to defeat Thanos in their Infinity
War how by dream walking with the dark
holes now we don't often discuss the
past possession of the dark holes and
who handed it off to whom something I
suspect that we will learn more about in
Phase 5 with titles like Agatha coven of
chaos but I think the 838 Illuminati's
win over Thanos was scripted for them by
Kang Kang had curated their timeline so
that 838 strange would use the dark hole
to defeat Thanos now why do we think
Kang was involved with this well two
major clues in this crime scene first
the guy that Ted Thanos has acquired
four out of six Infinity Stones he's got
the power the space reality and the Soul
stones but not the Mind Stone and not
the time Stone so this Thanos must have
been killed right before he would have
acquired the time Stone secondly it's
the way this Thanos was clearly killed
his own sword plunged into his chest now
we don't know which of these Illuminati
had delivered the death blow but given
the fact that this is a corporeal wound
and not like him blasted to Smithereens
by Blackpool or something I'm going to
assume that this was some kind of combo
Reed Richard slingshoting that sword
using his elastic body in the thanos's
chest why do I think that because Reed's
elastic slingshot Maneuvers are really
the one physical Edge he has over his
opponents it's one range attack that
Thanos wouldn't have seen coming but
more importantly this is a death blow
that needed Kang's patriarchal ancestor
to be in the mix that's why I think
Multiverse of Madness made sure to
include that line about Reed Richards
having children Reed Richards is a
distant ancestor to Nathaniel Richards
Kane so in the a38 universe Kang did
this so that these Marvel heroes would
have no need to have to invent time
travel to undo famous snap he limited
these Heroes to multiversal travel by
dreamwalking from the darkhold sorcery
not technological Quantum time travel
that Kang would use in the future they
use magic not science so that Kang and
only Kang would always have that
technological back doors or whatever
sloppy incursions their magic caused so
this right here on Titan is the moment
that Kang engineered thanos's death
right before the time Stone would enter
the play and snuffing out a future
in-game Time Heist which makes sense
because this battle of Titan was
conqueror Thanos at his most vulnerable
and likely was a Nexus moment for Thanos
to be assassinated in any timeline
that's why it makes sense to blame Peter
Quill for punching Thanos out of his
trance in Infinity War as one moment The
Avengers could have taken Thanos down
before the snap happened we're right to
hate Peter Quill for that they were so
close now of course quill still needed
to be part of this overall Dogpile
because when you re-watch infinity War
he totally provided essential
distractions for other Avengers to be
able to pin Thanos but really they were
so close to ending the 616 Infinity War
all that can would have had to do to
change the odds here would be to add
someone like oh I don't know Ant-Man
Ant-Man could have snuck inside the
gauntlet and wriggled it off the hand he
could have gone inside thanos's chest
cavity to give him a heart attack he
could have blown his butt out any number
of hypothetical what ifs here and for
Kang to be a true conqueror Thanos must
just be a villain from an older age that
merely played a part in Kang's
machinations and died at a deliberate
moment of Kang's choosing for most
realities that moment was definitely on
Titan except in 616 when Kang needed
Thanos to get far enough for the
Avengers to start putting the word
Quantum in front of everything let me
know your thoughts on this in the
comments below you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]